[Music]
Kassandra is with us in Boise hi
Cassandra how are you better than I
deserve welcome to the show how can I
help
so my husband and I we kind of have an
income issue we're just really not
making much we're kind of paycheck to
paycheck right now and he wants to make
a better income but also do something
that he loves and he really wants to he
really loves real estate ever since he's
in high school and he wants to start
wholesaling houses and so I kind of
wanted to get your opinion about that
and see if that's a good idea yeah how
old is he she's 27 okay all right and
what is his background and real estate
well he doesn't really have much of a
background in real estate we bought a
house last year but she does you bought
a house to live in last year or to flip
while we're living in it but it kind of
things it was kind of a beat-up house
that we kind of fixed up mm-hmm
okay is it for sale it's not for sale
okay so it's your home okay so he's not
in the wholesale business he bought one
house and you live in it yeah he wants
to he's thinking about doing wholesaling
yeah okay well wholesaling is very very
difficult for the uninitiated it is not
a point of entry for most people there's
two ways to do wholesaling one is to
actually buy the real estate and resell
it quickly the other is to tie the
property up with an option or a contract
to purchase and then sell that position
to an investor for instance you you
found a hundred thousand yeah it's very
difficult I mean I did it but I was I
grew up in the real estate business and
I've owned hundreds of pieces of
property and it's what I did some of
after we went broke years ago I didn't
have another K the credit or the
to buy a house so I just would tie up
one and resell it to another investor
but I knew all the investors in town in
a new real estate like the back of my
hand because I'd grown up in this town
doing real estate so I have a huge
background in it and so I was able to
pull it off and I made pretty good money
and you know made like six figures doing
it back in the 80s but you know it's a
it's a very difficult game but it is
something he could do on the side he
didn't even have to give up his day job
to try it would I quit my job and go try
to wholesale houses with what you've
just outlined for me absolutely not yeah
but but is it okay for him to try to
contract for something and if he doesn't
close on it there's no harm no financial
harm but he has to find an investor to
buy out that position so he buys a
hundred thousand dollar house for
seventy five and he tries to get an
investor to buy for eighty and he makes
the five spread
that's a wholesale flip without actually
closing and if he can pull that off
there's no downside to trying that I'm
just gonna warn him that it is a lot
more difficult than some weekend idiot
seminar series makes it sound like it's
like a real thing that you have to go
learn about and do you don't just walk
out there and everybody can do this and
everybody can buy houses at pennies on
the dollar and resell them just pay me
thirty-five hundred dollars from my
weekend seminar that's horse d'oeurves
that's what that is
okay so but if you can get with it if he
can get out there and learn it and just
try it and again be very careful to not
harm someone in the process or get
yourself in debt buying houses that you
can't do then I'll be fine with him
doing that as a side gig but he needs to
make a living during the day while he's
doing that yeah okay there's no downside
to try and it is her I really just
wanted to do something that he knew I
would enjoy well I want to do something
you'd love and enjoy - I don't want to
be broke though first goals feed his
family second goals feel all lovey and
enjoy II
right I don't really give it up about
his passion till the light bills paid
once the light bills paid and the foods
on the table for the kiddos then I'll
worry about your passion I mean this is
basic Maslow's hierarchy of needs you
take care of safety and security and
existence first and then you live your
passion there's no reason to say you
can't live your passion but I mean just
putting everybody out out to dry because
I want to live my passion that's not
that's immaturity so but I think you can
try this I don't think there's any
downside if this is what he wants to do
it's what I wanted to do I went and
learned it and did it he can learn it
and do it but it is harder than it
sounds and it you know I would lean into
it and learn to do it